baldie its Ross thanks so much for
coming on the show Ross Happy New Year
man good to join you thanks a lot
hey was there any ever anybody teammate
or opponent that you were like
legitimately a little bit scared of like
you really would not have wanted to mess
with that dude well you know the
forklift in Washington gathers jumpy
gathers was a guy that could flat-out
infer how he and the forklift Ross as
you remember was where he literally
would pick up the guard or Center and
just drop him in the lap of the
quarterback and once you got picked up
there was it was like you know it was
like a cartoon I mean you were pretty
much helpless and you you really you
wanted to win the game but you didn't
want to be embarrassed by jumpy gathers
out that was worse because being ruined
by your teammates in the film room is
worse than any collective loss by a team
III can see that for sure I want to get
to something you tweeted about Trevor
Lawrence during the clubs in Notre Dame
game a little bit later but first you
know I've seen so many of your baldies
breakdowns on the rookies Baker Mayfield
se Quan Barclay in particular I'm just
curious Offensive Rookie of the Year do
you have a guy you'd lean to well I mean
it's it's a it's a good competition this
year Ross it's a great rookie class I
mean there was a time when rookies were
basically redshirted in the NFL but not
anymore not with uh not with the talent
that they have and how seasoned they are
coming in but I as much as I love Baker
and I've loved him I never understood
why Cleveland would let him compete for
the job from the very beginning and
while I had to sit out for two and a
half games before he took over but I
still think se Quan was a guy I just did
something for the NFL and I had to put
together a highlight package of sake one
I ran out of time there was just too
many of them I mean there's eight plays
over 50 yards there's the 15 touchdowns
there's the catches
there's one-yard runs that look like
highlight reel type runs you know it's
going to be hard for for me to to take
anybody over say Quan right now led the
league and yards from scrimmage
over 2000 yards I never saw him either
nicked up or tired
in any game the guy was just a complete
machine start to finish all the way to
the final game against the Cowboys Ross
you know what's weird to me about him
Baldy and there's other great running
backs Todd Gurley Zeke Elliott etc I
don't think there's another guy though
that makes NFL defenders look as bad as
he does at times like sometimes when
guys are trying to tackle him he makes
him look bad or when he bounces outside
even guys that have an angle on him
balled him he he legitimately I think
it's fair to say at times makes NFL
starting defensive players look bad or
at least pedestrian you think that's
fair
yeah yeah they started week one in the
rain against Jacksonville I mean watched
Alvin Smith in miles Jack and you know
the whole group of Barry Church watch
them all just grab nothing but air you
know all game long and it went like that
all season and they constantly took the
wrong angles and then he just has that
ability just his balance his ability to
jump and make guys miss and land on his
feet almost like a ballerina at times
it's just a an incredible blend of all
of the great attributes you could
possibly want the ability to make people
miss the balance that he has and then
the strength and the burst from any
position is it's just it's really unlike
anything I've seen in this league in a
long long time and I I blocked for
Dorsett in Eric Dickerson and Thurman
Thomas and some Hall of Fame backs but I
don't remember any of those guys being
able to do the complete things that that
se Quan can do what about MVP Baldy can
you still make an argument for Brees or
is it just mahomes argument but you
can't make the argument from this
standpoint wise you can't give it to him
as a Lifetime Achievement Award
just because he's never won it before
you can't give it to him on that merit
yeah why he hasn't won one before with
all the accomplishments and everything I
don't know it but this year start to
finish Patrick mahomes was the best
player in this league and he didn't take
a Sunday off or a Thursday night or
Monday
you did take any day off he was
phenomenal every single weekend there's
only he's only the third guy to throw
for 50 touchdowns in a season but even
more than that was the percentage of
passes that were touchdowns I mean nine
percent of his passes were touchdowns
nobody in this history of the league has
ever come close to that number before
yeah and you know what - I almost feel
like Baldy the Saints defense playing so
much better in the second half the year
that almost hurts Brees and that it
makes it like what he did offensively
was less valuable we're talking the most
valuable player because that wasn't
really the case with the Chiefs they
needed every every throw mahomes made
whereas the Saints defense really
started to play pretty well so Brees
wasn't quite as valuable in those games
although we all know how great Brees it
I think that's that's a pretty good
point I want to get into these playoff
games with you as well I'm talking with
Brian balding or NFL Network does
terrific stuff on Twitter you got to
check it out baldies breakdowns he's
fantastic
so one of poll questions today Baldy has
been the wild card team that you think
has the best chance to make a run to the
Super Bowl and also the worst like the
least likely scenario of these teams
this weekend so give me a best and a
worst for the wild-card teams the eight
teams what you see them possibly being
able to accomplish well I mean the Colts
went down to Houston you know late in
the year and they stopped a nine game
win streak of the Texans and when you go
back and watch the game I'm sure you've
watched it Ross I mean they they got
some explosive plays out of the passing
game Andrew Luck was phenomenal they
handled the pass rush of JJ Watt and
Jadeveon just fine but they had a big
place to tee why Hilton and to Pascal to
Eric Ebron and really the Texas didn't
have much to answer for and that
defensively I mean they've been shutting
teams down and you have to really do
your homework to look at the Colts
defense and make sure that you know who
Marcus hunt is and Jabal sheared and
obviously Darius Leonard the group but
they're playing very very good defense
right now the shut the Cowboys
late in the year and so that be a team
on the can they go down and do it again
to the Texans I mean they just did it so
I think they have a chance to go do it
again
I always fun to talk with Brian balding
or a guy I've looked up to for a long
time in this business because of the
great work he does and the preparation
he puts in I want to get to a tweet you
had two tweets before I let you go ball
you won
hmm I think you said recently that the
Eagles might be better than they were
last year is that were you were you
kidding or do you really believe that no
I wasn't kidding I I mean if you looked
at the Eagles in week 16 and 17 last
year and losses on Christmas night to
the Raiders and then the loss of the
Cowboys the week 17 I mean Nick Foles
had taken over and he didn't look very
good and they kind of got hot through
the playoffs I mean he scored you know
13 points against the Falcons in the
first home playoff game and then they
just rolled on the Vikings and you know
and then put up all those yards and
points against the Patriots but they
look better I mean I think Golden Tate
is a better option right now at a wide
receiver
I think the offensive line got healthy
at the right time Nick Foles is playing
as good football as he did in his
playoff run last year right now and I
think defensively they finally found
corners that they believed in I think
when you look at you know what they have
out there right now it's better than
anything they had all year long and I
think the defensive front is better than
it was a year ago I think Michael
Bennett coming in I think
hello de nada coming in right now I
think they're better up front as a
defensive line you know what especially
as opposed to exactly this time of year
ago I think I think you make a pretty
good point I hadn't even thought of it
that way and then the other tweet and
you can always follow Baldy at baldi NFL
that's how you get at him at baldi NFL
it was during the Clemson er Dame game
and I I don't want to I don't have the
exact tweet in front of me but you said
something like you wondered I think if
perhaps Trevor Lawrence the Clemson
quarterback might even be the number one
pick in the draft
if he were allowed to come out in 2019
well I'm just watching a play and I've
seen him play a little bit throughout
the year rhasta Colin college football
on Saturdays at Fox but you know he's 19
years old it obviously is too young to
come out it's not eligible but when you
watch them and you look at what the
teams are looking for
I mean if mr. Biscay can be the number
two pick in the draft and traded up to
the number two pick to become a starter
and now in the second year leading a
team into the playoffs I mean obviously
a lot of parts in Chicago but that's
what teams are looking for they're
looking for that guy now I mean he's
only started you know I don't know eight
or nine games or whatever it is right
now but it looks like a good piece of
clay I mean the size the arm strength
the poise all of that stuff and he you
know the the quarterback that was there
before Kelly Bryan he was a good player
too but he was better and I just think
as much as teams are looking for that
guy there's a bunch of teams looking for
quarterbacks right now whether it's the
Giants or what the Patriots are gonna do
long term or you know just go through
the list of teams in this league you go
boy could you could you take in 19 year
old right now number one and develop
them and give them you know build them a
really good cast around them and could
he be that guy that teams are looking
for right now do you think forty that
it's fair that he should have to wait to
2021 or do you think maybe this is
something that we should look at cuz
watching him play that well in 2018 it
seems pretty crazy that he can't enter
the NFL so 2021 well I mean you're gonna
see guys taking out insurance policies
on injuries right now at that age in
college I mean Leonard fournette you
know and Todd Gurley these guys coming
out of the SCC at those positions they
look like they were ready to play right
away after a year and so you know before
any anything happens to him you almost
think gosh is it just like the NBA can
they be one and done physically that
gifted right now this early and just
banking on the potential I mean the year
that edger and James came out everybody
said that Ricky Williams was the best
running back except the Colts thought
that adren James only had one year of
tread off the tire at the University of
Miami he became a better player it is
probably a Hall of Fame player yet only
really played one year at Miami and so
it
been out there for a long long time that
there are certain players that are just
advanced and advanced in their
development physically and gifted and
it's going to come to a point where it's
going to become a fight again
to get these kids to stay in school and
to make them stay for you know the three
years into their tenure Brian always
appreciate the time check him out on
Twitter at baldi NFL he's a terrific
analyst for compass Fox NFL Network and
like I said if you're not checking out
his videos on Twitter you're doing it
wrong Baldy thanks so much as always
happy new year Ross thanks a lot buddy
I'll talk to you down the road all right
there he is Brian balding era for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]